it's a very dangerous job magic and
crime makes about like fireballs and
mummys got the good-good let me see let
me see what's going on you know I don't
like raspberry stop 32 to dispatch got a
call about two people rolling some
Scrolls
it's a Wiccan neighborhood and everybody
knows they don't cooperate I hate to say
it but it's the truth it is one time I
was a first responder on a broom
accident which was hex ting while flying
I was that ran a red flare well I'm just
telling the story ran a red flare and
t-boned a carriage yeah helmet would
have saved her if she was wearing one
but they never do yep can I talk to you
for a minute excuse me let me see that
ID and broom I don't you don't do it we
got a sweeper pointy hat no no helmet
either I don't don't even think about it
in pursuit stop or I will tase you
funny ball you're under arrest
we have a right to test silence anything
you can say will be used against you the
wizard court needs me sir I'm gonna see
that permit for that step back
typical really a lot of people don't
appreciate how difficult it is look I
just want to be clear for anybody who's
watching this I don't have anything
against Wiccans I have several Wiccan
friendly to me to Wiccan neighborhoods
they're not the safest know this job is
not dangerous as long as you have a good
partner who watches her back Jim and I
have actually set a couple office
records that's okay
Oh what do we got here we've got a
little colorist
how you doing tonight what you're
working on over here huh
hey keep your hands where we can see
them
I got a healing spell I gotta charge up
my man okay public do you have a healing
potion we're gonna wizard down we have a
wizard down first things first I was
calling for a healing potion something
the service is gonna work on a little
bit so Jim was reanimated by the
Archmage don't know how I feel about
that I wasn't asked about it you know
they got him problem papers down at the
precinct oh well you don't reanimate a
beat cop
it's like clipping his wings chopping
the horn off a unicorn
whiz cops is filmed on location with the
men and women of magic law enforcement
all warlocks are innocent until proven
guilty in a court of wizard law